toujours serrés et j'en ai s'est bien
passé
ce que tombe la foudre
ça se passera mieux la prochaine fois
j'en ai rien à [__] de ta conte
comment on dit déjà tant par à tournon
condescendance
ce qu'ils nient
tu me regardes ça cher tu fous là
d'ailleurs
c'est pas à l'école ça c'est les
vacances ah ouais tu quand même depuis
trois jours
mon coeur tu peux ramasser ça pour maman
s'il te plaît
je t'ai déjà dit que je veux pas croiser
ce petit bâtard chez moi mais est ce que
tu fais piquer le monde me manque pas de
respect oubli par duvivier
ta gueule tu as oublié ta dernière
dérouillée toi je vais t'apprendre à
manquer de respect
j'ai réussi à dresser ta mère je crois
que le petit bâtard comme toi sa me
faire chier jusqu'au bout
quoi vraiment
encore
sa fille
qui voit sa
tête
ou suis chez moi
m'appartient oui d'accord t'as raison
tout soit à partir c'est grâce à toi ce
n'est pas la rue
au pouvoir
je n'ai pas retrouvé leur dîner en
terrasse ou plus
et